welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and as we look at the Loki season 2
seriously what the hell is Miss minutes
yes she's the Beloved mascot of the TVA
she's voiced by Tara Strong and she has
a mystery backstory but she also has a
mystery Anatomy we do not know what she
is made out of like she isn't just a
projection on a computer screen or even
a hologram she has physical weight and
tangible mass and she's scary enough now
that we're afraid to ask her what that
weight is after looking closely at all
the footage of Ms minutes from the
recent trailer from all the episodes of
season 1 and various other clues in a
true Deep dive into a bevy of research I
have arrived at a horrifying conclusion
of what Miss minutes might actually be
and buckle up kiddos because we're gonna
have some Oppenheimer nightmares over
this one zagaftra has informed us that
entertainment journalists like new
rockstars are allowed to cover movies
and TV shows during the strike but we
stand with the writers and actors that
are currently on strike to get the
working conditions they deserve and
please subscribe to the Deep dive for
some crazy details No One spotted in
Loki season 1 and The Dark Knight okay
the new trailer for Loki season 2 shows
a past form of Ms minutes a paler
creative yellow orange wearing a skirt
and she appears briefly in a shot from
the 1893 Chicago World's Fair episode
Growing to gigantic size and chasing
down the fleeing Chicagoans
so in addition to this flattering skirt
it is worth noting that Miz minutes here
has an actual hour hand and minute hand
on her face remember in season one when
she was a darker shade of orange there
were no clock hands on her face could
this be an atomic clock thing this
version missed minutes ticking down to
some future that the season 1 future
version of his minutes doesn't even
bother keeping track of anymore keep
that in mind as we observed in season
one Miz minutes is not just a hologram
projection she has actual physical Mass
like when Loki tries swatting at her
with that rolled up jet ski magazine the
sound editors went to the effort to mix
in little Taps of her feet landing on
the surfaces and on the keyboard
where's your manners
quit it
that is not Max
when she was first introduced in the TVA
welcome video in episode 1 director Kate
Herron said that they plan to have her
jump off the screen at that point but
that would have been just too crazy for
the first episode The VFX team Luma that
created the misminute's effect told
variety that in addition to Mr DNA from
Jurassic Park they pulled from Felix the
Cat and from Betty Boop and overall the
welcome video was really a parody of
1950s propaganda films for kids A is for
atom and destination Earth the latter of
which was produced by a petroleum
company and the former anthropomorphized
an atom to acquaint kids with atomic
energy and transform it from a hulking
giant to a smaller cute form which in
its own way is even more terrifying the
Luma artist said quote but as you learn
more about the TVA we see her not just
as this mascot especially toward the end
of the series when we understand that
she knows more about this than we do and
she has an agenda of her own when she
becomes more Sinister than we actually
think she starts getting a bit more
naturalistic a little bit more dramatic
instead of having everything be
keyframed we actually did some motion
capture to get a little bit more Nuance
into the role which is not normal for
cartoon characters absolutely not normal
motion capture now we don't know if it
was Tara Strong who did this herself or
another stand-in actor but there is more
Humanity to this character like when
Loki asks her what she is in episode 2
she has a very creepy response can you
hear me
are you recording or are you alive uh
sword of both
remains making her both something that
was recorded and also alive as we all
are after the season one finale Kate
Herron told marvel.com that Miss minutes
was quote that devil on the shoulder
saying there's something a bit more
Sinister going on here with her we
always had a version where Loki and
Sylvie kept meeting her at the Citadel
at one point we had a fight scene with
Ms minutes in the Citadel we had all
kinds of stuff for her a fight scene
that now seems to be unfolding in the
season 2 trailer as we see some form of
Miss minutes can exist in the real world
She's Not Just confined to the halls of
the TVA we're in the Citadel at the end
of time but she's out here in the open
air notice how she is initially perched
on what kind of looks like Victor timely
we don't see his face but that does look
like his suit and that is definitely
rensslayer AKA Rebecca torment beside
him so it's like Miss minutes might have
emerged here to defend Papa but if this
occurred in 1893 Chicago why would there
be no historical record of a Victor
timely or his temporal Marvels for a
giant glowing Kaiju clock and why is the
1893 Chicago World's Fair better known
for figures like the mass murderer H.H
Holmes who preyed upon young people who
moved to the city for the exhibition and
confess to as many as 27 victims while I
believe this with Ms minutes was the
history of the 1893 Colombian exhibition
but it was pruned from the record now
long time new Rockstar's viewers know
how much we use geology and how long
we've been using it for but if this is
your first time hearing about geology
get ready for Blockbuster quality Skin
Care on a student film budget geology is
a 23-time award-winning skin hair and
body care company recognized in men's
health Oprah daily hypebeast birdie
Esquire and GQ geology's products are
just a handful of powerful proven
ingredients that have been trusted by
dermatologists for decades geology can
help you fight acne reduce oil-ness
prevent wrinkles combat dark or puffy
under eyes have smoother hydrated skin
and Target signs of aging everything you
need to keep your skin healthy no matter
how much you soak in the pool this
summer don't know where to start geology
can create a simple and effective skin
care or hair care routine for you all
you gotta do is take a quick 30 second
quiz right now if you use the code new
Rockstar's 100 geology will give you 100
off their award-winning skincare trial
set you'll also get an additional bonus
offer of up to 30 off one skin hair or
body products when you add it to your
trial it's truly a while to offer one of
the best they've ever given our audience
so click the link in the description or
go to
geolog.i.e
rockstars100 to get started remember
part of the tradition of the Loki Series
has been to take real world historical
mysteries and anomalies and to give
greater context around them through this
science fiction Loki season 1 retcon the
real world 1971 mystery hijacker DB
Cooper and establish it that was Loki
the void also included sightings of
ancient world wonders The Conspiracy
Theory links polybius arcade game the
USS Eldridge which is also linked to
conspiracy theories so the setting of
The 1893 World's Fair seems like it
might be doing a similar thing the Loki
season 2 trailer included a poster and
an elevator warning about temporal
radiation and you can actually see a
version of that poster among a number of
season two prop posters that talks about
how the suit that we later see worn by
Mobius to the trailer allows for 15
minutes of exposure near the temporal
core which tells us that the TVA this
structure is really a kind of temporal
radiation power plant using time as a
kind of nuclear Fuel and the way that
time is broken here causes that fuel to
leak out like a Chernobyl incident by
the way these posters also give context
to other trailer shots like your time
Cube atmosphere it also seems to be a
cube made of that same orange temporal
radiation and it's described in its
poster as largely non-toxic there's also
a lot of posters about the key lime pie
slices from the automat in the trailer
and I gotta talk about this because it's
crazy apparently limits TBA employees do
one slice per week requires tokens no
exchange for tokens and 17 minutes is
sufficient an unofficial misminute
Twitter account tweeted or I guess
x-posted everyone knows that apple pie
is better than key lime which I suppose
is a reference to the McDonald's
campaign that the Loki season is going
to be doing but for what it's worth the
working titles for Avengers King Dynasty
and Avengers Secret Wars are apple pie 1
and apple pie 2. so by working theory
for the key lime pie is that since it is
a bright shade of green and key lime pie
normally isn't that vibrant it's kind of
more of a mustardy yellow color this
could be kind of a Soylent Green used to
keep the TVA Employees fed and happy and
brainwashed like the Kool-Aid feeding
them the gooey radioactive waste of
prune timelines and variants that they
gotta do something with but coming back
to our question of what is Ms minutes
well if we were meant to see the TVA as
a radioactive power plant with temporal
radiation and a core Victor timely's
exhibition could have been a
presentation by an early American
inventor someone between Edison and
Tesla's era and the era of Einstein and
Oppenheimer imagine a future Nathaniel
Richard scientist going back to this
point in history to alter history to
bypass the 20th Century's greatest
mistake the Eternal fastos Folly and
Hiroshima the unleashing of atomic
energy onto the world and instead
offering an alternative a different
cleaner energy temporal radiation using
time as fuel that could be what Victor
Timeless machine is showing off here
sparking at the exhibition like the
splitting of the atom but instead
splitting space time to release temporal
radiation that might be a different kind
of mistake and instead of Mr Adam what
gets unleash instead is Ms minutes the
crowd turns on timely and Ms minutes
turns on the crowd and then bottles and
captures this crowd in a vast time Cube
atmosphere a prison abducting and
absorbing this entire Midway plays on so
the Chicago Colombian exhibition into
what we now know as the architecture of
the TVA and taking along with it the
first wave of TDA employees he remains
could alter this history with a
replacement world's bear that we know
from our real world history and
attribute the missing people got
abducted to the dozens of victims of
notorious 1890 serial killer H.H Holmes
don't tell me it's too soon it was like
130 years ago I don't think Marvel is
too afraid of retconning that history
into this MCU history as dark and
horrifying as it actually was read The
Devil in the White City it's disgusting
what happened so what is Ms minutes not
just light but hard light Tim oral
radiation sentient time bottled into
this useful assistant to teach Victorian
era America how to use a cleaner but it
turns out even deadlier form of energy
than fissioner Fusion ended up being and
trapping the replica of the World's Fair
into a power plant for all time always
let me know your thoughts on this
explanation of Ms minutes and subscribe
to all three channels in the new
rockstars Network you can follow me on
all social platforms at eavos thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
thank you